[Musik]
ein wunderschöner früh abend erwartet
uns hier in unserer kleinen süßen micro
welt und meine lieben freunde ihr habt
gerade schon gesehen wir haben jetzt
nämlich ein intro für das projekt
minecraft mit luca und da möchte ich
mich direkt mal ganz ganz ganz ganz toll
bei jerome bedanken ihr findet hier ums
kanal unten in der beschreibung verlinkt
ihr findet ihn in den kommentaren
verlinkt ihr seht hier gerade einen
screenshot eingeblendet jerome macht in
minecraft animationen auf seinem kanal
und hat sich gedacht mensch das projekt
mannschaft mit lukas ganz cool da mache
ich ihn doch mal ein intro und das in
träume dann in zusammenarbeit gemacht
die letzten wochen und es ist wirklich
sehr sehr sehr sehr geil geworden also
danken dir die roben auf jeden fall an
der stelle ihr seht allerdings auch
schon dass ich hier gerade meine sachen
so ein bisschen rein packe und mir
erstmal nicht sagen lasse von der so das
ist der grund warum ich warte wie soll
ich denn nacht machen der fiebert dem
sonnenuntergang entgegen
hier vorne packe ich jetzt noch eben die
ganzen holz sachen rein die erde behalte
ich mein brot behalte ich auch und wir
haben ja auch noch auf unserer
leuchtturm insel hier vorne der sieht
schon echt sehr welt aus also das ist
wirklich brutal die sache es halt auch
das letzte video auf grund der tatsache
weil wir diesen fetten leicht umgebaut
haben ja das video ging deswegen auch
fast 40 minuten deswegen wird das
heutige video auf jeden fall ein
bisschen kürzer und ich habe mir für
heute auch nicht so viel vorgenommen
eigentlich wollte ich in die hölle gehen
wo das ist nämlich das ding warum ich
dachte das ist vielleicht doch keine
gute idee ich wollte halt in die hölle
gehen um mir ein bisschen quatsch zu
holen um halt ganz einfach ja ein
bisschen was für die strandhaus will
einmal wieder zu tun die sache das
allerdings dass ich mir dann gedacht
habe mensch wir haben in den letzten
folgen so viel geschafft die trauminsel
also die tiere beziehungsweise baum ins
was ist das hinter mir
aachen delfin ach so oder so gewesen
wenn wir die letzten folgen so viel
geschafft wollte ich sagen da bin ich
wirklich extrem stolz auf uns und auf
dieses komplette projekt das wir in der
heutigen episode einfach mal einen gang
kürzer treten können ich warte jetzt
extra mal die nacht ab beziehungsweise
ist ja schon die nacht eingebrochen um
zu gucken ob das mit unserem lichtsensor
da oben funktioniert das jetzt natürlich
blöd dass ich mich auf dieser insel hier
befinde und nicht auf meiner kurz
geblieben bin allerdings es klappt nicht
gedacht ach du scheiße der gartenstadt
von dias mit chat
das muss doch nicht davon lassen uns
überhaupt nicht unterkriegen freuen er
zum glück diät ruhe hier überhaupt nicht
berührt von daher ich werde auch mal
direkt schaffen gehen also war der
einzige grund warum ich die nacht kurz
abwarten wollte um zu schauen ob das mit
dem tageslicht sensor weg sind aber es
klappt alles und das freut mich auf
jeden fall wir erwarten einen
wunderschönen neuen morgen hier hinten
ist unsere insel ärgers ist nicht
wirklich wundervolle vorne
das ist wirklich sehr sehr geil dass ich
höre es glätte der ist tot wir haben
hier vorne an unserem leuchtturm noch
ein bisschen was zu tun ihr seht ihr
schwebt hier so ein bisschen in der luft
von daher euch eine ganz kurze tipps wie
ich hier ein bisschen was runter bau und
dass hier ein ganz kurzer dauer
[Musik]
so hier vorne sie das ganze jetzt so aus
habe ich alles durch sand ersetzt und
hier an der seite steht er jetzt auch
hier vorne auf den ecken hier kann ich
das kommt es in so bauen hier ist noch
ein bisschen natürlich mit und wenn wir
hier jetzt von der seite gruppen seht
ihr auch dass er hier vernünftig drauf
steht hier habe ich alles abgedeckt das
mache ich auch noch mal eben so gehen
hier nehme ich mal weg und dann steht da
auch hier vorne drauf hab ich jetzt
einfach erde gelassen weil er hier auch
ein bisschen erde ist wir haben jetzt
hier vorne noch unsere kiste und hier
vorne auch und hier noch eine menge
reichen setzlinge drin ich habe auch
gerade noch einen knochen bekommen das
heißt ein bisschen knochen wir brauchen
wir gleich noch für unsere insel hinten
allerdings setzt sich jetzt
das ist mal ganz kurz ein bisschen erde
hat der kripo ja alles gerade leider
kaputt gemacht sodass hier vorne bei
euch jetzt einfach so dass das ein
bisschen auslaufend ist und hier setzen
wir jetzt auch so ein bisschen setzlinge
hin nämlich 1234 und dann vielleicht
noch hier in 56 hier hintergrund ja auch
noch einsetzen 7
und vielleicht noch hier und nirgendwo
hin 18 haben wir hier auf jeden fall
auch ein paar mehr bäume der hier muss
vielleicht sogar gar nicht mal unbedingt
sein und dann hier an der seite ist
vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu nah dran
dann können wir den hier auch ein
bisschen weiter unter setzen und hier
vorne und dann auch noch mal ein
entsteht also direkt am wasser das sieht
vielleicht auch ganz cool aus irgendwie
hier in oder so dann haben wir hier auf
jeden fall auch noch ein bisschen
begrünung das knochenmehl packe ich
jetzt nicht hier auf den boden denn so
viel habe ich nicht davon ich habe nur
drei stück gerade allerdings nehme ich
hier vorne schon mal die eine hälfte der
kiste damit wir benötigen das knochen
mir gleich hinten für die situation war
hier so jetzt ist die letzte folge hat
mich total verrückt gemacht das war ja
wirklich geisteskrank wie lang die ging
also ich habe ja eh schon zweieinhalb
stunden aufgenommen das dann allerdings
schlussendlich das video auch irgendwie
40 minuten fast lang wird hätte ich auch
nicht gedacht allerdings nehmen die kids
hier vorne auch mal mit dem
blumenkohlwolken zusagen im leuchtturm
beleuchtung ist glaube ich auch noch
alles in ordnung da können wir noch mal
ganz kurz gucken ich denke nicht dass
wir hier allzu häufig in zukunft sein
werden allerdings können wir ja ganz
normal von oben den blick ein bisschen
genießen
der ist ja täglich geisteskrank also
hier oben das klappt alles mit dem
tageslicht sender und wir sehen hier
unsere insel waren zoomen sieht schon
krass ausser händen die trauminsel damit
haben wir heute noch ein bisschen was
vor und mit der widget insel haben wir
auch was vor allerdings auch wenn wir da
mal hierhin gucken sehen wir hier vorne
muss er die mob falle noch hin hier war
mir in der höhle
hier haben wir kein fenster und dahin
haben wir immer noch diesen unterwasser
tempel wo wir auch noch hin müssen also
wir haben noch einiges zu tun wirklich
meine lieben freunde allerdings soll die
heutige folge wie bereits gesagt zu
beginn ja auch ein bisschen kürzer gehen
wenn ich möchte mich auf ein paar sachen
konzentrieren letzter zeit ein bisschen
zu kurz gekommen sind finde ich und die
tür zu beginn des projekts extrem
wichtig waren wie beispielsweise dieses
ganze einfach mal mehr schätzen ich
meine schaut euch das hier mal an wie
wunderschön das ist und im vergleich zu
minecraft wie ich es kennen gelernt habe
damals vor acht neun zehn jahren ist es
wirklich so geist kann geworden alleine
delfinen da vorne die ganzen neuen
mosley dazu gekommen zum beispiel
eigentlich ingos verzaubern gucken was
passiert wenn ich eine spitzhacke
reinlegen
da kriegen wir nur haltbarkeit und
effizienz das braucht jetzt nicht obwohl
wir können mehr effizienz darauf
verzaubert damit zumindest effizienz 1
dann geht alles mal ein bisschen
schneller lapislazuli packe ich mal
wieder hier rein wir müssen demnächst
auch wirklich mal das dingens machen
dass verzaubern von ja bei mir wird es
in die kommentare geschrieben und dann
weiß ich ja was die leute dann meinen
ich sollte mir erst mal ganz kurz die
sachen beziehungsweise erst mal kurz in
den knochen mehr für das hier denn hier
ist ja auch über die luft geflogen und
hier war gar nichts mehr am start vom
von einem komischen gras und so und hier
auch nicht weil hier auch wenn man die
luft geflogen war
ich werde die sache jetzt doch erst mal
nicht sortieren denn eigentlich habe ich
alles was ich brauche schon mit dabei
hier vorne nehme ich mir noch ein
bisschen weiter mit dass benötigen wir
noch und karotten habe ich nur reine ich
hab doch noch das könnte ich auch mal
kurz wieder anläufe pflanzen ich hab
doch hundertprozentig noch mehr karotten
hier vorne perfekt damit möchte ich mal
ganz kurz eben einem
wird diesen sachen möchte ich mal ganz
kurz eben rüber zur villiger insel hat
schon immer noch die beiden schildkröten
vorne drin aber kunst reden und zack
hier fordere er nicht zufällig hinsicht
zu trauminsel mai nicht denn da haben ja
wirklich noch eine menge tiere die ja
leider in den letzten rennen zu
verfolgen verstorben sind aufgrund von
qype explosionen monstern eine kuh
leider aufgrund meines schlag das findet
man noch so geil dass wieder hinten das
piratenschiff einfach sehen deswegen
möchte ich die tiere auch erst mal noch
ein bisschen miteinander paaren zum
beispiel hier vorne das schaf wo haben
wir dann noch unscharf die ganze insel
soll ja richtig zum leben erweckt werden
ich kann erst mal ganz kurz die
schweinchen nehmen wir haben nämlich
hier vorne direkt als und hier
wir können die beiden sich schon mal
fahren das schafft damit ist dass der
bürgermeister das ist nicht der
bürgermeister wo ist denn überhaupt der
bürgermeister offen grab irgendwo der
bürgermeister du passt sich mit dem hier
eben dann nehmen wir die kuh mit und du
kommst nämlich mit hierzu anderen kuh
die hier vorne steht dann habe ich auch
noch samen mit am start da kann man
nämlich auch das hühnchen hier klicken
und auf das hühnchen hier dass
wissenschaft danke ich war es hier haben
wir noch in münchen also ihr beiden
parteien auch mal ganz kurz und ich weiß
nicht ob noch irgendjemand hier gerade
verfügbar ist keine ahnung warum das
hier so übersteht und weg von dem baum
hier vorne aber der connected sich
wahrscheinlich mit dem holz von den
anderen sachen hier
wir haben auf jeden fall wieder ein
bisschen was gutes getan hier auf der
insel und die haben sich ein bisschen
weiter vermehrt so dass wir demnächst
hier wirklich extrem extrem extrem viel
bewohner am start haben und
können wir auch mal eigentlich ganz
kurze schrecksekunde einlegen
sie doch extrem schön aus einfach mit
der sonne da hinten ich finde diese
trauminsel wirklich so wundervoll mit
diesen ganzen blumen und mit den ganzen
bäumen und dem ein bisschen beleuchtung
hier auf diesem kleinen stein ziegeln
mit den laternen die sonne geht schon
wieder unter das heißt ich werde mich
mal ganz kurz hier zu meinem kostros
osten mit dem ich werde mich mal ganz
kurz die vorne auf meine reise bett
legen denn wir müssen doch noch mal ganz
schnell robert zum leuchtturm da habe
ich nämlich eine sache vergessen die ich
eigentlich wohin machen wollte was ich
euch allerdings auch hier mal ganz gut
sagen kann ist dass hier die kirche
hinkommen wird dafür eure resonanz
wirklich extrem positiv als ich vor zwei
drei folgen gefragt habe ob er eine
kirche hin soll halo soll meinen
schatten
hier kommt eine kirche hin das finde ich
ganz geil weiter hinten ist ja der
friedhof und verbinden wir das mit dem
weg hier vorne weil wir ja schon denke
ich eine menge tiere verloren haben und
ich ja eigentlich im kompletten projekt
hier wo ist mein brot hier ist mein boot
ich wollte eigentlich im kompletten
projekt keine tiere töten das hat leider
nicht so richtig geklappt ist allerdings
auch nicht weiter schlimm ich hab ich
noch einmal von irgendwas tierischem
ernährt in diesem projekt also klar
jetzt irgendwie will ich hab' ich glaub
ich mal getrunken oder irgendwie sowas
hab ich schon mal milch getrunken
ich weiß es und ich habe auf jeden fall
kein fleisch gegessen und keinen fisch
hier vorne der leuchtturm fragt wie teil
das aussieht mit dem schwert und mit dem
leuchtturm
das ist wirklich ich kann sich oft genug
sagen ich habe auf jeden fall zwei
fehler gebaut haben ein leuchtturm die
mir in der letzten folge aufgefallen
sind hier vorne könnte ich auch noch ein
bisschen sand dran setzen sie auch ein
bisschen doof aus mit der erde und dem
mit dem gerade mit der erde und dem
stein hier fordert das war direkt mal
fischen sich bezirke das könnte auch
schneller sein
hier vorne auf jeden fall mit dem sand
einfach mal direkt hier hoch stecken
und ich habe keine fehler gebaut ist mir
in der letzten folge aufgefallen denn
die treppen hier habe ich ja so 12 und
dann abwechselnd gesetzt das habe ich
allerdings hinter der ganzen leuchten
situation nicht gemacht habe ich mich
ein 23 gesetzt und es dann falsch
gesetzt also diese beiden muss sich
umdrehen sagt wie susan richtig an so
die beiden nämlich und ich setze die so
und so hin und genau das gleiche mache
ich jetzt auch noch mal auf der seite
hier
denn die hier muss auch umgedreht werden
und die muss umgedreht werden die müssen
mich so und so hin
das hat meinen augen ein bisschen
getriggert und ich weiß dass der ein
oder andere jetzt vielleicht sagen wir
auch lokale wie pingelig aber ich finde
ganz baut dann sollte man es richtig
bauen hier vor das war schon ein baum
gewachsen sieht sehr gut aus wir steigen
allerdings direkt wieder rüber ins
bettchen beziehungsweise neben der
vergangenheit gelernt was ich gerade
tausch alter einsamen gegen vier
buchstaben ich war mal ganz kurz wieder
zu unserer armee hier vorne und parke
das büdchen und sortieren nun meine
ganzen items denn danach haben wir auf
jeden fall ein ziel halogene kuba
fordert er durch tun egal
also
man kann sagen was man will
aber er ist einfach
es einfach ich mache mir nun allerdings
noch mal ganz kurz eine neue achse denn
davon besitzen wir keine mehr und ich
mache mir auch ganz kurz noch mal ein
bisschen mehr packen denn davon haben
wir auch nur noch zwölf stütze ich
gerade 1978 ist oder noch mal wieder 56
schrift schön hier wieder die stecker
rein und auch die kohle hier vorne
wieder hat ein
die sache ist allerdings dass wir unsere
ganzen smaragd einmal mitnehmen werden
denn ich habe ja hier vorne noch meine
stein säge stehen die bauen wir jetzt
auch mal ganz kurz ab und ich werde
jetzt erstmal einem villiger hier
fordert dennoch keinen beruf hat den
steinen segen beruf geben ich glaube er
hat ja den lesepult beruf bzw
bibliothekare halt hier neben steht ich
werde jetzt allerdings ein stein
täglichen leben stellen
[Musik]
jetzt hat michael fischer sein ich habe
nur fischer hat er den fischern fischer
versucht büro verloren und er geht zur
stein säge und ist jetzt maurach perfekt
dafür bin ich auch unter die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich über einen maurer
angeblich quad bekommen kann deswegen
muss ich erst mal ein bisschen mit ihm
tauschen habe ich auch keine ziegel 33
tonklumpen konnte ich gerade finden
deswegen werde ich dir jetzt mal ganz
kurz tauschen gegen smaragde und diese
smaragde jetzt wiederum gegen diese
ziegel denn nun hat er die stufe
erreicht dass er so komisch probanden
sollte das tut er allerdings nicht doch
er tut und jetzt ist er lehrer legen das
heißt wir können schon neue sachen
tauschen können stein tauschen und wir
können wie das markt getäuscht
ich tausche jetzt einfach mal weiter
meine smaragde einfach nur um ihn auf
ein höheres level zu bringen wie viel
muss ich da tauschen sich danach
tauschen sowie ziege brauche ich muss
den hoch kriegen aber die quarz kriege
ich habe mir jetzt gar noch mal ein
bisschen steine geholt also vielleicht
kriegen was damit ja hin
deswegen einmal kurz die steine aber das
geht auf jeden fall schon mal deutlich
besser hat zack zack zack
und er ist schon wieder auf einen neuen
level das heißt er verwandelt sich
wieder sollte jeden moment wieder
anfangen zu blumen warum ist bisher
nicht so
das fällt ja nie ganz ganz kurz die
haken nehmen wir das immer wieder neu
anpflanzen hier hier ich noch samen am
start nicht noch aber die habe ich hier
vorne drin da nehme ich jetzt einfach
mal ganz normalen habe ich hier noch
kartoffeln genau ich letztes mal
kartoffeln hin so ein bisschen dann
könnt ihr hier vorne auf jeden fall so
ein bisschen an startern mit brot geben
als spannend na gut wenn ich mir ein
bisschen brot kommen ich frag jetzt
allerdings ganz kurz noch mal den maurer
hier an die das ist der rüstung schmid
mit dem dürfen wir uns uns aber auch
nicht verhindern so bei dem hier kauft
jetzt auch erstmal ein paar sachen dass
es wirklich der mit drei hosen die sache
ist einfach dass wir unsere ganzen will
ja ich weiß ist auch gar nicht warum mir
grad zu viel auf einem haufen stehen ich
mal ganz groß ein mal so dann geht jeder
mal wieder dann aus zurück die sache ist
dass wir die ganzen village einfach
hochleveln müssen sodass sie uns dann
schlussendlich irgendwann diamant sachen
geben also rüstungen man hängt er fest
oder was ist seine mission hier vorne
ich werde das hier abbauen
und das vielleicht auch jetzt wirklich
fest sorgt kann ich mal ganz kurz hier
wieder die falsche platzieren und auch
wo ist das andere
[Musik]
das geräusch hast du geräusch ist dieser
typische
wenn ich verrückt und dann zu schauen
und weg von mir
wo ist denn diese komische leitplanke
die ich da oben noch dran platzieren
wollte ist jetzt weg oder der typ gegen
wieder aufgenommen oder liegt die
obendrauf welchem weg habe ich die nicht
aber davon abgebaut
ich kann jetzt auch nicht obendrauf die
arag die brücke steht wieder freunde die
sache ist allerdings dass das mit dem
handel wirklich extrem lange dauert also
ich würde sagen dass wir das dann doch
auf ein anderes verschieben dass das
warum wird das hier kein gras wo ich den
fahrer ablenken sie sieht jetzt auch
unfertig aus
ach ich weiß es nicht freunde die sonne
geht auf jeden fall schon wieder runter
und ich bin ganz ehrlich ich würde die
heutige die sohle an der stelle auch
beenden ich weiß dass wir nicht so viel
geschafft haben wir haben eine menge
gehandelt mit denen dahinten wir haben
den leuchten mensch einmal ganz kurz
die können wir auch jetzt mal wenn wir
erwarten dass die sonne untergegangen
ist können uns das ganze ist aber von
ihr fordert anschauen ob das alles
funktioniert guck mal wie geil das
reflektiert sie herr unfassbare da ist
ich wollte heute eigentlich auch noch in
die hölle gehen allerdings dachte ich
mir mensch mal ein bisschen eine folge
zum runterkommen nicht so viele sachen
nicht so stressig nicht so viel an
einander nicht für mich dreieinhalb
stunden aufnehmen und dann hier gucken
und da gucken und dann den leuchtturm
fertigbauen und ich weiß wir kommen
richtigkeit selber spielt sich gerade
der baum im schwert
kann ich mich auch im schwert spielen
[Musik]
jetzt spiegelt sich auch nichts mehr
ich höre auch immer noch den zombie hier
und müssen wir auch den hilfspaketen ich
wollte allerdings nur ganz kurz sagen
dass sie mich für euren riesigen
sportlern und sollte ich weiß ich sagt
das ziemlich häufig und nervt auch
einige allerdings ist das projekt
mittlerweile so weit gekommen dass wir
ein gott verdammt das intro am start
haben danke nochmal an jerome an der
stelle ist wirklich sehr sehr er von dir
dass du dieses intro auf die beine
gestellt hat ihr habt hier oben auch
gerade infoguard eingeblendet gesehen
also schaut gern wiederum vorbei der
macht unfassbar geile sachen der macht
minecraft animation minecraft sorgen
macht er auch und das sieht so geil aus
mit dem leuchtturm nach vorne
mit dieser reflexion von dem mond also
ich weiß nicht warum das ding da oben
jetzt noch nicht so richtig angegangen
ist ob das noch ein bisschen dauert aber
es ist doch jetzt ist es an gegangen das
ist brutal
das wirklich wunderschön also das ist
gerade das macht mich richtig stolz über
dieses projekt soll dass die heutige
folge ein bisschen kürzer war und dass
wir eigentlich nicht so richtig auf die
kette kriegt aber außer die tiere ein
bisschen paar ein bisschen mehr machen
und ein bisschen leucht kommen da hinten
ausbessern die ganze insel aber sowas
muss auch mal sein
übermorgen auf eine neue folge 20 uhr
wir bauen die kirche auf meine
trauminsel hinten und jetzt hab ich auch
ein bisschen schiss dass hier und da
kommen die leute schreien wächst hier
es war doch dazu klar das war doch
wieder so habe ich die nicht erst mal so
klar dass hier direkt wieder im team
erwartet
finde ich auch sogar das im intro dass
da wirklich ganz ganz viele kripo hin
gepackt hat aber gut okay ich hab bei
den strom vorbei ich hoffe dass in
vorgefertigte meinungen kommentare wir
sehen uns übermorgen wieder um 20 wenn
ich die kirche bauen
[Musik]